Configuring Enterprise to use an SMTP server allows you to enable some useful features such as allowing administrators to send email invites to new users or send password reset links to existing users,
allowing users to automatically receive end of scan reports, and allowing administrators to receive system alerts such as low disk space warnings.
You have the following options. You can use an HTTP proxy server to connect to the SMTP server, providing the proxy server does not require authentication.
You can set an HTTP proxy server by going to the settings menu, choosing network, and then scrolling down to HTTP proxy server, making sure that use proxy to connect email server is selected.
Alternatively, you can connect to an external mail service by going to the settings menu and choosing email.
Select connect to an SMTP server, enter the SMTP server hostname, the port used for sending emails, and in the from address field enter the email address you want BuP Suite Enterprise to use when sending emails.
To reduce the risk of messages being blocked by spam filters, use an email address registered to your email service provider.
Select authenticated, enter the username and password for the email account, and select use TLS.
If you are connecting to an internal email service, you can configure the details on this same page.
You may not need to select authenticated or use TLS.
You can verify your SMTP connection by clicking on the send a test email button.
Check that you received the email and that the link it contains works.
If the link doesn't work, go to the settings menu, choose network, and confirm that the web server URL, the public facing URL for the enterprise server, is correct.
Check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check that you have to check